[Music]
small X stated that he wanted them to
appear to attack him defended Smollett
also stated he wanted the brothers to
catch his attention by calling him an
empire F Empire end defended Smollett
also included that he wanted Ola to
place a rope around his neck pour
gasoline on him and yelled this is mega
country the Cook County Prosecutor's
Office today laying out in detail all of
small its alleged wrongdoings now given
all that overwhelming evidence doesn't
even have a defense well who should we
ask well Harvard Law Professor Emeritus
Alan Dershowitz has staged some of the
most infamous or famous defenses in
legal history in the OJ case and many
others he joins me now okay Alan what
small its defense here
well his defense is that nobody ever
gets prosecuted for making false reports
Tawana Brawley remember back that back
in the day the people who defended her
and created her fraud and went free and
went on to political and media careers
there are many many other instances of
people who make false reports and
they're never prosecuted look we have to
presume everybody innocent if the facts
are as the police say they are if
actually payments were made and a plan
was hatched to put a rope around the
neck and a police report was filed then
we have a potential for a serious a
crime I'm surprised that they charge
them only with some kind of disturbing
the peace that doesn't sound like this
is what happened here so we have to wait
and see even as a defense attorney I was
a criminal defense attorney too but
should this you should this matter here
I mean that to me given the toxicity of
the charges given the the the heat that
is on Chicago and the race relations we
just heard two very well-respected
former superintendent of Chicago PD and
current journal order police president
this is it's just hot there so shouldn't
just be like we're here well just get
probation maybe he'll go I get you know
just be probation it's I'm gonna be a
big deal to me that just seems
ridiculous with you I agree with you we
have to look at the context we have
look at the pressures on the city and in
the end I do think a case like this if
the evidence is that overwhelming as it
looks like it is they'll probably be
some kind of a plea bargain some kind of
a deal who'll probably admit it and
apologize and and do some community
service but I do think I agree with you
I think people who make false reports or
to go to jail I think you know in the
Bible if you falsely accuse somebody you
get the penalty that the person would
have gotten had the accusation been true
so if in fact these people had attacked
him in this racist way and put a noose
around his neck they would have gotten
some years in jail if you're gonna
follow the Bible this guy ought to get
the same penalty that he falsely accused
other people of getting we still don't
know enough about the case in the sense
of were these people going to take the
rap if they will court were they going
to go to jail they're gonna sing like
Canaries for just thirty five hundred
bucks and they get extra five hundred
when they came back I love that big
detail look I think in general there
ought to be a policy of prosecuting
vigorously people who make he's being
framed it's unfair and I want to play
something for you from one let's look at
the facts yeah Mark Geragos who joined
the team he went was on CNN and he's
tipping their hand on what the defense
will be and then your friend Branson
from LA chimes in let's watch somebody
tweeted yesterday of the day before and
I thought it made a lot of Sun she said
this is a police department that has had
some issues I think there are issues
with the Chicago Police Department as a
general proposition whether or not they
are alleged to have treated people of
color fairly whether or not they are
capable of doing an investigation
without any difficult issues arising so
now it's just gonna be the Chicago PD is
corrupt so Jesse's innocent I love that
one - well it's it's more than corrupt
what the suggestion is is they're racist
and I don't know how that cuts but look
I never condemn a defense attorney for
trying to be creative and trying to come
up with any possible plausible defense
that's what the Sixth Amendment to the
Constitution is about
let's wait let's not rush to judgment
this does seem like a strong case but I
want to hear all the facts before I come
to any conclusion all right Alan thank
you so much